un devastador incendio en una estación
del Instituto Nacional de Migración
ubicada en Ciudad Juárez que conecta con
El Paso Texas en Estados Unidos deja
decenas de muertos y heridos que fueron
trasladados a hospitales los servicios
de emergencia atendían a las víctimas
mientras los familiares esperaban alguna
noticia cuando se hicieron las 10 de la
noche empezó a salir humo por
todos lados fueron a los hombres lo
sacaron de ahí a todos y los hombres son
los que se quedaron allá dentro nunca le
abrieron la puerta pero no nada me dice
nada de ella no sé qué va a pasar uno
pregunta ya y lo que hacen es darte una
mala contesta No te dan una información
uno quiere saber porque uno se preocupa
por la familia y uno para saber qué va a
pasar con ellos que le van a hacer lo
van a devolver según la información
revelada por el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador la conflagración fue
causada por los mismos migrantes que
querían evitar ser deportados Como
protesta
en la puerta del albergue pusieron
colchonetas y les prendieron fuego y no
imaginaron de que esto iba a causar esta
terrible
desgracia lo que sabemos hasta ahora es
que son migrantes
Centroamérica fundamentalmente
y algunos de Venezuela los albergues de
Ciudad Juárez están repletos debido al
creciente número de migrantes que
intentan llegar a Estados Unidos por la
frontera mexicana las nuevas reglas los
obligan a solicitar asilo en algunos de
los países por los que pasan antes de
llegar a la frontera estadounidense
aquellas personas de Haití Venezuela
Nicaragua y Cuba que hayan cruzado la
frontera ilegalmente podrán ser
deportadas inmediatamente a México según
las medidas impuestas por Washington el
flujo migratorio ha aumentado un 8% en
territorio mexicano según datos de la
organización internacional para las
migraciones